[Applause]
great how are you it's funny too because
you wouldn't know it but we're 3 000
miles apart
this is magic of television 2021 style i
love it i love it this is and we didn't
know that we were wearing the exact same
like color palette we are like matching
look at this it's like a greige fantasy
that being said i am
freaking out over your shoes it was the
first thing i noticed i was like oh wow
those are good shoes they're rick owens
and i like have them in like seven
different colors because i'm obsessed
with them i mean you really do have such
phenomenal style and i've been watching
your youtube videos uh for your beauty
tutorials
yeah that's new new a new venture tell
me all about this because i think this
is really awesome
well i mean you know i've always worn
makeup and i remember being like a kid
in the 90s and it was so taboo for a boy
to wear makeup except for a couple rock
stars that i saw on television i
remember seeing dave navarro on tv in
his island remember
his eyeliner and his nail polish and i
was like that is so cool that's so me
and i was always playing with makeup at
home and doing it on other people and
then i just slowly got into it in my 20s
more and more and i actually worked as a
makeup artist for a few years before i
ever got any gigs so i made a choice at
some point around like 24 i'm like okay
i actually i want to be a performer so
i'm kind of move away from makeup but it
was like a side gig for me it was my
being a waiter before anything happened
well and you're so good at it thanks i'm
going to turn it over to my co-host ruby
hello um i think you have some beauty
questions actually
we do i do so it is like rapid fire so
i'm going to ask them really quickly so
you're going to have to give me an
answer right away within 60 seconds you
ready yeah i'm ready i'm ready adam
let's do this together 16 seconds so i'm
going to read them really quickly adam
what's
what's the secret to a smokey eye
use your fingers
liner
yes drew what's one makeup product
that's always in your purse
uh concealer
adam what's what's hotter for a night
out red lip or high shine gloss
it depends on the eye smokey eye nude
lip
light eye red lip
green agree love it drew how can i
prevent mascara from clumping use a
flower beauty's warrior princess mascara
never plays it does it
[Applause]
i will send you some adam okay great
adam how often should i be washing my
makeup brushes
i mean they say once a week but i'm
terrible at it so wash them more than me
please
okay
drew what is one beauty product worth
splurging on
i say more skin care than makeup
yeah if you're going to spend money do
it on skin care
yeah
love it love it
uh
now i want to talk about clash of the
cover bands um
now this is a jimmy fallon produced show
um with his production company and i
watched the first episode uh first of
all twitch who's so amazing is the mc
and then oh my gosh meghan trainor hello
one of my favorite all-time
nantucket girl which is the coolest um
and
uh
i i was watching it and i i'd like to
say something to you which is
i'm so glad
that you
gave constructive criticism because i
feel like when i'm watching those shows
everybody wants a boost of confidence
very very kind but what i really want to
see
is help and guidance
how do you have the confidence because
your constructive criticism is really
good what is your process
well i'm an aquarius so i am like super
analytical i'm always trying to break
things down so as i'm watching i'm
breaking it down but then once i have
those ideas of what could be improved
upon i also put myself in their shoes i
wasn't a contestant on a singing show
you gotta you gotta wrap it up in in a
nice way in a way that doesn't offend
them in a way that doesn't throw them
off guard in a way that feels helpful so
i think it's using that empathy with the
analyzation
that's the process you know the other
thing is that we had some real talent on
the stage i mean there were some of the
acts that we were the three of us were
just blown away by i mean
real real iconic impressions
impersonations that we're talking about
like
people that you do like a double take
and you're like wait what you know and
it wasn't until they got a little closer
to the edge of the stage that you went
okay you're not you're not uh britney
spears you're not jlo i mean it was like
it was wild is it true that you used to
um work on a cruise ship
that was that was one job of many jobs
and yeah i was like 19. so i worked on
it for 10 months as a still a teenager
when i got hired and it was just
it was a very
surreal experience it was sort of a
little bit like a college dorm it was
performing for
a lot of senior citizens on this cruise
line it was kind of geared towards them
but they loved the show the audiences
loved the show and and i got to sing a
lot of amazing music and see the world
so it was a lot of fun and where was
your favorite place that you got taken
on this beautiful odyssey
well i mean that was the one thing about
it was i was 19 i had just come out of
the closet i was like raring to go out
and party and socialize but being an
older cruise line clientele we would get
to a port at 6 00 a.m
and leave at 6 00 pm so i could never go
out
it was like day trips only um we
actually we were in new york on
september 7th oh
yeah and we were stranded outside of
boston during the the whole thing it was
it was a wild time it was really crazy
i'm gonna parlay this right over to ruby
because you have a question that when i
heard what your question was i was so
curious for the answer so please ask it
sure so my question to adam is
if you were
not a singer songwriter what would you
be doing
with your life what else would you be
doing
you know i've always been a creative
person i would probably go into some
sort of design
i would make
clothes or or
makeup or
like interiors or something something
visual i love that
[Music]
you